while the Algerian government is opening
its airspace to allow the delivery of
humanitarian Medical Aid to Morocco
Algeria had banned fights to its
neighbor and severed ties two years ago
over Moroccan territorial claims to the
disputed region of Western Sahara well
let's bring in Las and Haddad he is a
Moroccan Senator and a former Minister
he joins us now from Rabat Senator as
we've been saying these areas are
incredibly remote how is search and
rescue going at the moment
well I mean like it's it's very very uh
High kind of mountains and some of the
villages are really isolated and then
the road between Marrakesh and Chardon
is a sinus Road and when there is any
kind I mean when there is heavy rains or
heavy snows and when there is also like
earthquake like what happened then the
road was also is blocked because there
are all kinds of rocks that block the
road so you need to do that kind of
clearing the road and that happened like
early morning on Saturdays for the
ambulances to go and then get to people
who are injured and also for the teams I
mean to come and then start to do really
really heroic rescue operation and
they're going and then to have a sense
of the full picture you are going
through some serious roads like over
tens and tens of kilometers as you're
going from Marrakesh to Sheridan and
there are Villages scattered on the
right and on the left over like a radius
of about 40 kilometers this way and 40
kilometers this way and those Villages
you need to go through roads and
sometimes the roads are not paved so you
have to bring in the Army in order to
get to the population in villages and
then you start the rescue mission at the
same time that you are evacuating the
the injured and some of the injured will
be evacuated just to makeshift hospital
that has been built by the Army and some
of them which are taken by helicopters
if you cannot use their ambulances
because of of because of the the cases
that they have there and then you need
to provide them with water and you need
to provide them with food some of the
communities are really really far away
and then they have been reached only
yesterday afternoon some of them
probably like during the night and but
there are like on the local level some
help that is being done by the local
authorities within those kinds of
villages and volunteers but also with
the with what you call civil protection
it's a very heroic effort that the the
rescue teams from the Army from the the
Civil protection from the jean-darmory
and from I mean like you are doing and
then it's a very multi kind of of
pronged kind of operation because you
need to rescue people who are under the
rubble you need to get the injured you
need to also get those who are that it's
it's a very very complex kind of
operation in a very high terrain some of
it's really not accessible in in
villages like 80 percent of them were
built the traditional way you can see
that Villages have been have been wiped
out but you can see that the modern
buildings for example a mosque or a
house that has been built in modern ways
has not been has not been destroyed so
but there are Villages which have which
have been wiped out and we're seeing
those pictures Senator obviously huge
huge Logistics challenges that you're
describing there but are you now
convinced or confident at least that all
of the communities that need help have
been reached or are there still Villages
that that the government has not been
able to help yet
no I I think with the Army the Army has
a lot of know-how and the nose the
terrain very well because the Army
intervenes every winter in order to deal
with population that is being strapped
there because of the snow so when there
is the snow the Army will get in and
then build like Villages uh build like
like hospitals and then evacuate people
and deal with them in terms of food and
all of that so they know the terrain
they know how to intervene they have
done that in Africa and all of that so
with the army with the helicopters with
the airlifts and all of that I think
most of the communities will have been
reached probably there are a few
Villages here and there because this is
these are very scattered communities
over very high mountains indeed and in
some of that is and and it's not like a
linear thing I mean it's very very and
you are talking like you are talking
about like four provinces the central
provinces the house but where is that
has been hit ceradent and the South has
been hit on the west also has been hit
and each in each of those that are
communities and when we're talking about
communities these are scores of
communities that need to be reached and
all of that I think with the logistical
uh might of the army I think most of the
communities might have been but might
have been reached but I think it's a
real heroic effort that is being
undergoing in order to deal with the
population in order to rescue it
certainly sounds that way uh Senator
sorry I do want to ask you because this
was an unusually strong Quake obviously
Morocco has had to Grapple with
earthquakes before but this one was
particularly strong I know that people
have been told not to go back inside
their homes how long is there a
potential danger of aftershocks when
might this kind of guidance from the
government change for them
I I think the Aftershock is something
that nobody will predict but I mean most
of the experts says that said that
Aftershock have happened but I mean like
there might be other aftershocks we
don't know I mean what kind of magnitude
generally they say that aftershocks are
like us I mean are weaker there are
aftershocks that have happened is that
enough we don't know I I think even
experts there is no consensus with
regard to that what is sure is that the
high Atlas Mountains is on a fault now
he's on a very uh I mean like active
system kind of of region we didn't know
that before because I mean like the last
kind of earthquake that happened there
was 120 years ago so we thought that
there are other places the agadir region
the alpha SEMA region are the most
active that's where the efforts in terms
of anti-systemic kind of construction
has been done but now I think the
government needs to pay more attention
to the high Atlas Mountains and secure
those areas so that they could be like
they could be they could be safer in the
future for the population of course
a Moroccan Senator and also a former
Minister speaking to us from Rabat so
thank you so much for joining us here on
Al Jazeera and we wish you and your
government all the best in the days to
come
thank you